[Applaudissements]
moi je suis tranquillement en train de
repasser vos chemises et qu'est ce que
je découvre
il ya un nouveau numéro 1 coiffe c'est
pas numéro 1 sans numéro un bis voilà et
que je sais pas qui je suis numéro 2 -
oui c'est vrai j'ai rien fait je suis au
tranquillement en train de repasser les
chemises laver votre voiture je
redescends je suis numéro de julien mahé
bas c'est comme ça va la vie c'est comme
ça on peut pas toujours du bon allez on
y va regarder je l' ai déjà dit mon
coeur n'est pas un boomerang un jour le
combat il sera plus la touche femmes et
filles j'ai pu la toucher a organisé sa
presse organisée à broc et ça regarde ça
ça c'est l'état de mon coeur en jachère
bon on regarde quoi il touche pas tu
appelleras dont tu fais ton père charre
tu touches pas toiture touche pas ton
père les squares certes mais sa vie nous
embrasse moi idiot lui direct à les
pulsions restes humains fera adopteunmec
avait lancé un grand concours sans make
a adopté et vous êtes le numéro un
camille combal sur meeke a douté
produits d'or 2016
bravo à nos commerces
vous allez faire aisément
confortablement votre compte bancaire
mais simplement en verlan très loin de 3
je suis retourné vers les classiques
notamment m au ts et on sait que thierry
beccaro et souvent tout seul dans ses
livres dans ses délires dans ses délires
en plateau le public
les candidats personnes le calq le
calcul mais aujourd'hui il a trouvé une
candidate qui est en kiff devant lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
je vous donnais trois pense que vous
allez devoir faire attention
le chaton vénère